[driving music]
[sound of wood sliding]
[snapping into place]
(Emma)
This was definitely a
part of the degree that I was
very interested in pursuing.
One of the most important parts
of the education,
just understanding
that what you're drawing
and what you're
looking at on a plan, how that's
actually physically represented
on site is extremely important.
(Noah)
I've been here for like
seven or so years
and I've seen these houses
pop up in different communities
and sort of
seeing how they've changed
hands and seeing,
you know, residents
living in them for years on end.
You know, it does make you
sort of feel a little bit more
connected to communities
throughout New Haven.
[snapping into place]
(Adam)
What is fundamental
to architecture is shelter,
and so when we're talking about
serving a population
who has experienced
vulnerabilities
of perhaps not having shelter,
it really foregrounds
the importance of
making spaces that are both
areas of refuge,
but also areas of aspiration.
So it really grounds
architecture
as a service to people.
♪♪